thank you for this very kind
introduction and and first I would like
to tell you that I know that you were
probably expecting to have misses from
the line to be ready to speak to you
today but unfortunately she has been
asked to be in in Berlin for very
important meeting with but Libya and I
was supposed to come with her but now
I'm here on my own but I will speak to
you and what what you said about our
Digital Agenda first agree to tell you
that I'm extremely happy to be in Munich
again that's for one of my circumcision
de lot of time here over the past 10
years I have many many friends maybe I
have something special with Berlin
because my daughter was my Berliner
lives in Berlin and my two grandchildren
in Berlin but still I love a love unique
so thank you and it's good to be back
here together together with together
with you so it's true that today we will
speak to you but the European Digital
Agenda and and you are actually right
you must see this this commission that
we call between us the vandalian
Commission under two directions first
the digital the transition the digital
transition and then of course the Green
Deal or vice-versa extremely important
to objectives ambitions that will
probably have a very very strong
influence for us in Europe and for our
children over the coming years and
decades and within this commission and
objective I will speak to you but my
portfolio which which is pretty loud
because as you mentioned I'm in charge
of internal market but also when we
but in general market for the first time
or so digital and for the first time or
so for defense and space and if you look
at what do we have in common with in off
this huge what for you including
industry including services including
tourism including media by the way but
what we have in common is definitely
data data will change everything
transversely and this is what I would
like to speak to you about today when we
will speak about data
it's clear that I used to say hopefully
if we work well together regarding the
way Europe will handle its own data it
will be before and then after
von der Leyen Commission because yes
objective and of course we end up
incontinent and I will come back on this
but objective is that is that I have a
fine that I see here coming from Siemens
hello Joe if we look at what we have
today
in terms of data it's true that my
ambition is that European data will be
used for a European company in priority
for our for us to create value in Europe
and it's true also that if we look in
the past some say that we missed a
little bit this first data wave my
answer is first that no europe is no
lagging behind its data battle yes this
first battle was mainly made on personal
data and it's true that today if we look
at the planet as a virtual data lake
the number of data that we have
available on our planet today is roughly
35 to 40 Zeta byte of data in other
words 35 to 40 thousand billions of
billions of that this is today what is
available when we speak about data the
good news is that now we are doubling
this amount of data every 18 months in
other words that's a little bit like a
new role in terms of data creation every
18 months we are doubling the number of
data created in the beginning of
humanity now so it means that at the end
of Oman that together with the
salamander lion and my colleagues the
planet will move from certified
zettabyte today to 175 data byte at the
end of 2020 for bringing of 2025 it
means of course that in Europe since we
generate roughly 20 to 25 percent of the
data produced in the world it means that
between now and the end of our mandate
the data that will create in Europe will
be 40 zettabyte of data in robots the
exact number of what we have a new
manatee today so that's the good news we
may have missed a little bit the first
wave let's be clear my job is that we
will not miss this second wave and by
the way well is that I will come from
this that I will come from mainly Jim
snubber from industrial data and I
thought you know in my position Jim and
don't speak about any company I don't
give any name of any company and I try
also don't speak to any country except
York but still it is true that if we
look at today
where these data are located the famous
certified Zeta byte of data mainly today
80% of this data are located in data
center or cloud and already already
early twenty twenty eight twenty percent
on the pervasive way everywhere
beginning of some in connected car some
in virtual factory some in machines some
in smartphones sermon and in hospital at
twenty percent which is a pretty good
number big number but what will happen
during our mandate this if there is
something that we need to remember this
number eighty twenty will move to twenty
eighty in other words in 2025 from the
famous 175 data byte of data twenty
percent of those data will be located in
cloud and data centers and 80 percent
everywhere everywhere and that's a huge
change of paradigm and of course as you
know we will create value more and more
locally where data are produced adding
artificial intelligence and computing
power more and more locally where that
are produced of course will continue to
swallow some metadata to continue to run
machine learning and so on but this
change of paradigm is happening now it's
now with edge computing with everything
that we will be the consequences of this
will change drastically our way to
handle our data to see what we can do
with our data and of course in term of
cyber security believe me it is changing
a organ everything and again it's our
job at the Commission to prepare
together with the member state of course
this change of paradigm which is lagging
huge opportunities in for us as long as
as long as we have a clear vision
of what we want to do how we want to
behave with with our data and I remember
them reading I remember Jim we're
together five five six years ago we were
advocating I think we were CEO of
another German company I don't give
names I want you of another company I
don't give name either no conflict of
interest by the way I don't have any
more sales I'm totally free but still
with Jim snubber
we were advocating I'm starting to say
hey in term of industry data European
data must be store and process locally
in Europe under European rules and of
course it's our job to give rules
we don't want again to give two more
rules that we have to be clear what our
rules what are our values so that and by
the way what kind of rules applied on
the data processed in Europe and believe
me my former life all my customers were
coming to see me and say Jay we okay you
are now data but we want only European
laws to applied on our data not some
extra territorial laws applying on our
data even without us knowing what is
happening with audit so that's of course
something that we are working on and our
mission definitely in this post cloud
era 2080 is to define simple rules so
that everybody will be comfortable with
the way we are using our data and of
course mainly for our European
enterprise s Emmys startups of course
everybody is welcome to come in Europe
but again you can count on me I will be
extremely clear on the rules that we
will apply on companies entities
processing our data in Europe and that's
of course an extremely important subject
especially when we speak about AI and we
will have also an AI vision ambition
strategy it's normal we will have to
express also in the algorithm that we
will use in Europe our values but you
are specialists in this room and you
know that what is AI about AI is first
data valuable data
yeah his algorithm ai is computing power
and it's my job to make sure that we act
quick we create a favorable landscape
for these three dimensions that's my job
here again I don't put any invisible
barrier I just want to make sure that
everybody understand that in continental
Europe we are driving car on the right
side that's it
that's my job and everybody is welcome
as long as you fulfill our requirements
I will be clear I will be strong because
at the end of the day we are talking of
the future of Europe here we need
partners we need everybody and by the
way we have the talents we are here in
Munich I am amazed of the talents we
have in Munich and in Bavaria but we
have talents everywhere
of course we've gotten into a nine siege
it's so true that when I'm going in the
in the world especially in my previous
life I mean I find Europeans everywhere
especially in this environment
everywhere so we'll make sure that our
young talents will be able to find jobs
here I will I will of they to stay in
Bavaria it's so nice and elsewhere of
course in in Europe infrastructure for
this to happen of course we will need
the right infrastructure first computing
power and it's extremely important that
we monitor our computing power more and
more in Europe we work on this we have
us PC will continue to monitor this we
launch new initiative we speak in few
minutes but one of my favorite subject
quantum but still before to speak about
quantum we need to continue to enhance
this and believe me that's a very
important program that we will follow
carefully at the Commission level but in
term of infrastructure of course I need
to speak a limit on the 5g deployment
because obviously 5g deployment and
especially standalone 5g in two or three
years will be a critical architecture
following of course to run and deploy
this reason that I gave you
8020 2018
and of course having the ability locally
everywhere to deploy antenna will become
smart antennas with AI and computing
power locally and bedded in each antenna
so that we'll be able to create local
interaction which we which we change as
a paradigm that we describe it of course
5g is something which is pretty
fashionable these days but as a former
chairman and CEO of a big telco operator
I know this seems like pretty well and I
just want to tell you why it is normal
that the Member State decided to take a
specific look at 5g because 5g is not
the deployment of a new and Ants
telecommunication network it is
something new it is a new architecture
totally new gsm 2g or 3G or 4G at five
5g is not for G + 5 g standalone 5g is
something totally new which will allow
again to develop many many new
applications to run many critical
applications for all our fellow citizens
in Europe will be in smart cities will
be in connected car will be in hospital
will be in retail store will be
everywhere and of course a lot of these
applications are the responsibility of
the states to make sure that everything
is well developed the way we want and
with our own values needless to say that
when you have such a massive deployment
with so many smart antennas each point
where you create a data is a potential
entry point in terms of cybersecurity
we change it which is changing
drastically drastically our way to
monitor cybersecurity at the level of an
approach are at the level of a state at
the level of the Union because of course
everything is interconnected this is why
we needed to have a collective approach
on this issue here again I will not
speak about anybody it's not my job I'm
just taking about Europe first I'm going
to tell you that I'm strongly believe
that Europe has everything in hands to
lead the rest inside G and I'm a little
bit annoyed to hear that we are late we
are nowhere in Europe and so on
it is just not true it is just not true
I'm an engineer scientist myself and I
can tell you that today Europe owns
control more than 50% of the patterns
and social patterns of all the 5 G's
more than 50% china owns 30% and the
u.s. 14% so that's the way it is that's
a fact
so please just realize that here again
we are leading the rise in terms of
innovation and again decisive patterns
and I'm talking of big numbers here so
we are again big companies in Europe
able to deploy first the non-standard
and 4G network which is what we will see
in the next few months which is which
will give more bandwidth for end-to-end
customers and within one to two years
the standalone 5g where the smart
antenna out and everything
and this is today available but what is
making fuzzy again different than other
deployment is that today to run full
stand-alone 5g network the software
needed for this are probably one of the
more complex and largest software in the
planet today
huge huge software kilometers and
kilometers and kilometers of cord lines
of course first when you have nothing to
compare with the software needed to
around or 4G or 3G network and nothing
to compare of course when you have such
a huge huge software first you have also
of course blogs and remember that they
announced and this is done intentionally
but you have bugs when you have a bug
it's enough it's an entry door for
people entities whoever who may have bad
ideas or behavior spirit but in addition
to this you need to download new
releases every two weeks because again
of the size of the software and then
third we are we have more than 100 telc
operator in Europe and and of course
some will be able to monitor but few of
them to monitor this huge software and
to maintain but most of them will not
have the skills and the ability and will
probably subcontract the old monitoring
of the system to a third-party entity as
a supplier or a third party and of
course we want to make sure that this is
done under our rules and Jim like we
said for data I will favor this to be
done in Europe under European laws and
here again I'm welcoming everybody we
are welcoming everybody we just want to
be clear and for this specific
deployment we will have specific holes
it's not me watching this
it was first the Member States in March
2019 or decided to collectively discuss
together how to handle this new
deployment fantastic opportunity for
Europe fantastic
then the Parliament two weeks later and
then both of them and the state member
as the commission to monitor a
discussion between the member state to
define what we called between us a
toolbox of what should be the checklist
but it will be demanding checklist
regarding the criticality of the
deployment of these networks so a
checklist that each country and telco
operator should fulfill to make sure
that it is compliant with our interest
and values and as you know a lot of work
has been done under the UN commission
and will be and as continue to be done
with a new commission of relevant a lion
and we will present at the end of this
month
the result of this toolbox which will be
extremely important for everybody we
would like to deploy effigy Network and
to make sure that we are all aligned
I repeat everybody is welcome in Europe
but more and more we will issue clear
rules and everybody will have to fulfill
all this I say all so wait another two
weeks and you will have this toolbox but
I'm impressed by the way by the work
which has been done with the Member
State at the first time by the way in
our story that we are aligned on a
specific subject like this in
telecommunication and again it's
probably because 5g is more than a
telecommunication with pure
telecommunication Network
so critical technologies critical
technologies is what will be next
with such a huge amount of data we will
need more and more computing power more
and more computing power and here again
I'm fighting so that we'll be able to
have our own resources in Europe which
will fulfill by the way our needed in
term of power but also energy because as
you know data here are consuming a lot
of energy more than 5% of the co2
emission worldwide are produced by data
centers and so on so we have to make
sure that everything will be reduced in
order to fulfill our requirements of
being a zero co2 continent by 2050
computing power and this is where of
course we start to think and to speak a
lot together already session here I
think about quantum and quantum
computing first quantum quantum
technologies will be the big story the
big story for the next generation by
well gee if I was young I think I will
start to start up in quantum for another
life it's absolutely fascinating we have
so many capacities in Europe is amazing
by the way just remind you that quantum
was invented by a bunch of young
physicists one century ago German
Italian French Danish we all know them
and now it's time to see the first
deployment
it's fascinating if I'm told if we are
able to speak today the way we speak it
is because Lazar it is because atomic
clock it is because all these things
which are the first application of
quantum technologies but of course
quantum technologies will probably I say
probably arose
to have the next generation in term of
computer I don't say I don't say here
that we will see within the next five 10
15 years a few quantum computing
computer but what I'm saying is with the
research that we have in Europe and
elsewhere on the planet I am absolutely
certain that within the next five year
we start to see some quantum accelerator
blowing by using some some device being
able to entangle 20 cubits and we can do
this already what you think the noise
going to accelerate drastically some
specific algorithm and to embed it like
if you have a CPU on a supercomputer a
GPU you will have this quantum
accelerator I know many companies
working on this some of them are
European and of course the Commission
decided with the Contin manifesto to
invest 1 billion euros in research here
so I'm expecting to see the first
quantum accelerator within the next 5
years to be able to accelerate some
specific algorithm again going to
increase drastically computations or
ability to find an information in huge
data legs and here again we will do that
this will happen in Europe
I'm amazed I know most of the research
center working on quantum annealer in
the world you will be amazed to see so
many Europeans how many Europeans are in
this centre in Europe of course but in
the u.s. in Asia including in Australia
so anyway my message here is that we are
not late we understand what is at stake
we have the team we have the skills we
have the you have the will we have the
ambition and I think we understand also
what we are what we're talking about so
the good news is that we will do
everything so that Europe will not miss
the new data wave so industrial and b2b
data wave will do everything it takes we
do everything to be extremely clear in
our requirements so everybody like
always will be welcome to come to work
with us but not vice versa
thank you all
[Applause]